a question I'm asked not infrequently is
can you tell me why climate change is
actually bad like I think the whole
thing's overblown how is it going to
impact my life and there are lots of
ways to answer that question you could
talk about threats to food security from
droughts and heat waves you could talk
about fragility in the global biosphere
because of species loss or geopolitical
tensions because of mass migration
caused by climate extremes but this week
specifically I want to give a more
specific answer health and there are two
reasons to do so this week specifically
first in Dubai cop 28 is happening and
for the first time ever they have a day
focusing on the impact of climate change
on global Health but secondly some huge
new research has just been published
focusing on the impacts of climate
change on health now climate change has
some very obvious impacts on health heat
for example as the global temperature
rises and extreme events become more
extreme and more frequent more people
will be affected by conditions like heat
stroke as precipitation patterns change
and extremes get more Extreme More
people will be affected by flooding
which poses a direct risk to life but
also a secondary risk through waterborne
diseases we Define the excess mortality
of climate change as those deaths which
have occurred due to the emission of
carbon dioxide and raising of the global
temperature that would not have happened
in a world where we didn't change the
climate but this misses some of the
health burden of climate change because
many of the secondary impacts of climate
change are non-lethal and while a large
part of this excess mortality will be
due to those quite obvious factors a lot
of it is due to secondary effects things
like changing patterns of tropical
diseases reaching into the mid latitudes
but also things like changes in renal
disease or allergies or an area that is
very under researched the impact of
climate change on mental health for a
good review of this the medical journal
the lanet publishes a annual publication
called the countdown which analyzes the
overall burden of climate change on
global Health there'll be a link in the
description but the largest most
pressing stress that climate change puts
on global health is air pollution ution
from a health point of view we're
interested in contaminants in the air
that are toxic so CO2 um you know for
example is very problematic for a
climate change point of views but it's
not directly toxic uh to humans unless
it's at extremely high high
concentrations so we're um mostly if you
look at what governments regulate on the
basis of protecting Public Health it's
certain pollutants that include
particles so particulate matter uh which
is a combination it's a sort of mixture
of things Some solid some condensed
liquid as well and we're interested in
particles that are of a certain size so
we focus a lot on the smaller particles
that can go directly into where the air
exchange happens in our lungs so that's
what we refer to as pm2.5 this is
Professor Katherine ton one of the
authors of an international study
published this week in the British
medical journal analyzing the impact of
burning fossil fuels on global health
and specifically looking at the role of
pm2.5 air pollution this is produced in
the incomplete combustion of fuels and
so is added to the atmosphere when we
burn coal oil and gas and their derived
products for heating transport and
electricity we breathe them in and uh
they interact uh at the as I mentioned
with these smaller particles they go
directly down into basically the alola
where we are exchanging oxygen for
CO2 and can have some Direct response in
the lungs but what we see is that
particle exposure triggers many uh
systemic processes so you get
inflammation you get oxidative stress
you get many things that affect the
whole body air pollution is not just an
issue for the lungs but it's it's
essentially associated with almost every
disease you can think of um in a way I
think it's useful to think of smoking we
know smoking is basically bad for pretty
much everything fertility your skin uh
premature aging air pollution is is a
lot like smoking these are products of
incomplete combustion just get much
lower concentration than when you're
actually actively smoking so the big
question how many people die every year
because of exposure to PM 2.5 in the air
they breathe and the resulting heart
attacks and strokes so there are
different estimates um but most of them
sort of range uh but they're all in the
several millions of deaths per year so
roughly between four and eight uh using
uh different methods basically to
estimate the the the attributable
mortality burden to air pollution so
it's huge it's really a large a large
number and to be very clear this isn't
just a problem in places that you may
think of as having very polluted air
like China or Korea this is a global
problem because exposure to even
relatively low concentrations of PM 2.5
has significant Health impacts this is a
problem that affects you pretty much
anywhere you live it's a huge Public
Health burden and just to put it a
little bit into perspective um you know
if you think about the number of deaths
from covid in 20120 you know it's
somewhere around three million but we
have much more than that even in the
lower range uh you know of air pollution
related deaths the estimates uh you know
are much more than that and they happen
every year I previously made a video
about air pollution and the health
impacts but I wanted to make this quick
video partly because of the timing and
partly because this research takes
things a step further than what I talked
about in that video and asks what
happens to the excess mortality if we
stop burning fossil fuels because pm2.5
pollution comes from both anthropogenic
and natural sources sea salts windblown
dust pollen so not all of those deaths
would be avoided if we stopped burning
fossil fuels the question is how many
and how do you work that out so the way
we typically approach this is um through
some sort of modeling where we have an
an idea of the emissions so how much air
pollution are is fossil fuel burning
putting into the atmosphere and then
basically modeling how that those
emissions move around in terms of
dispersion and transport across the
planet there's a lot of atmospheric
chemistry that goes on and that's what
we're breathing and then we use evidence
from the epidemiological literature
which tells us for a unit increase in
exposure to air pollution how much
increase in mortality in this case would
we estimate so linking together this
sort of models on the exposure side with
the epidemiology allows us then to
estimate uh the the number of deaths
that you could expect under a certain
exposure and essentially what we
estimated is that you would save
essentially five million deaths per year
61% of that total burden from from air
pollution so there's some other
contribution there that's other
anthropogenic air pollution uh as as
well as the natural component 5 million
deaths avoidable every single year to
put that in perspective that's like
every single person in a country the
size of New Zealand dying every single
year due to breathing in the byproducts
of burning fossil fuels and as I already
said there are many many other forms of
mortality linked to burning fossil fuels
and the resulting climate change which
brings us to cop 28 and for the first
time a day in which they weigh the
impact of climate change on global
health is is it fair to ask you for
another wasted ineffective cop how many
more lives are are wasted how many how
many more people will die because of
climate inaction that will take place
this week so it's several Million Lives
um and and that's not considering uh
basically the other diseases but you
know I according to the the paper that
we just published it's about 5 million
lives that's the true cost of delay uh
by not phasing out fossil fuels one more
year and what would you want to say to
world leaders if if you were on the the
podium at cop 28 and had the chance to
address all the the heads of state what
would you want to say to them uh that
the climate crisis is a Health crisis
and that it's you know the negotiation
is not just about uh you know the
concentration of CO2 in the atmosphere
it's about how many lives are are
basically at stake in these negotiations
and it's a huge number and that should
you know I think really shift the
dialogue cop 28 is a shambles and
frankly so are cops in general at this
point if you're not aware for the past
several years fossil fuel Lobby groups
have been one of the largest delegations
at these conferences designed to combat
climate change I'm sure that has nothing
to do with the persistent lack of
ambition about phasing out fossil fuels
or the watering down of language or the
fact that this year the hosts the UAE
have been doing behind the-scenes deals
to expand the use of fossil fuels and
lock countries in into their use going
forwards oh wait no those two are
obviously connected this year as with
previous years activists and scientists
will be invited to cop and they will
repeat their demands for the phase out
of fossil fuels that this is a crisis
and we need to do something immediately
and government officials will agree they
will nod their heads and say yes this is
very important and then they'll go home
and they will enact policy that doesn't
reflect this our very own prime minister
in Action Man himself has said that the
UK has a great track record at these
conferences and we should be proud of
what we are doing to combat climate
change and yet has consistently rolled
back policies designed to reduce
emissions and has in fact leaned into
the culture War propagated by right-wing
media in order to appeal to his ignorant
aging voter base the Prime Minister and
leaders around the world are not acting
on the advice of their scientific
advisers they are acting on the advice
of their financiers and I don't mean
they're economists trying to improve the
paychecks of people who actually live in
their countries no they're doing this to
try and improve their own bank accounts
and the bank accounts of people who have
put them into power and nowhere is this
more obvious than in Dubai this year
like I'm glad that these new stories
have come out I'm glad that these behind
the-scenes deals have become public
knowledge because they were always going
to happen I didn't have a doubt in my
mind that this is what was going to
happen at cop this year I'm just glad
they got caught this year will be
another year of wasted opportunities of
inaction and insufficient ambition
around the phase out of fossil
fuels and it will kill millions of
people we often frame in action on
climate change as making the future
worse that by not taking action today we
will make the world that my daughter
will live in worse and this is of course
correct it is making that future worse
but it ignores the harm being done in
the present a small country is dying
every single year because of air
pollution caused by burning fossil fuels
and the industry that's producing that
pollution is being actively supported by
World governments 7% of global GDP is
spent on subsidies for the fossil fuel
industry the previous video on this
channel detailed a version of the 21st
century in which Millions perish
hundreds of millions are displaced Wars
occur and that is the good version of
this Century the version that we're
basically already committed to the
version that is still possible if we
take immediate ambitious action to phase
out the use of fossil fuels but failure
this year in Dubai by the people who
represent you and me as I fear will be
inevitable will only drag us further
from that future and towards something
much much Bleaker and I don't know about
you but that pisses me off I'm sure
there will be some people watching this
maybe even some people at cop who will
ask but what about the social cost of
carbon is it really worth spending all
this money to transition away from using
fossil fuels and some deaths to avoid
the annihilation of the natural world
the very systems that we depend on I
want to be very clear millions of lives
are lost every year and we can prevent
that and also prevent so much more we
can Safeguard society as we know it we
can prevent a mass extinction occurring
on a geological scale and if you think
that arguing over change is more
important than that then you are a ghoul
I question not only your Humanity but
your basic reasoning if delegates at cop
28 do not demand a phase out of fossil
fuels and an immediate transition to a
decarbonized economy then they will have
to weigh millions of lives every year on
their conscience and if they don't make
such demands we'll know why you know
something that I think about all the
time and that you know how do we convey
the sense of urgency
uh that everyone seems to understand
with covid-19 you know but this is this
is this is a crisis this is an emergency
we should have the same sense of urgency
about uh about climate change and about
uh air pollution and uh I think this is
you know why we keep trying to get the
numbers out and get attention about just
the scale of the uh the health burden of
of air pollution because it's huge and I
think
it's uh you know not something that
people that's at the top of their mind
very often but it but it should be based
on the numbers it absolutely should be
this is a crisis we should we should be
you know treating it like one this was
an unusual video for me and I I think
I've made it because I've had enough
making the previous video on this
channel just snapped the future into
Focus for me and it made the idea the
seemingly inevitable idea of failure at
cop 20
impossible to bear I believe that cops
can accomplish the change that we need
in fact they may be the only way that we
can coordinate Global Climate policy in
a meaningful way the systems are in
place the Paris agreement was a good
start what we now need is for the
delegates at these conferences to take
the problem as seriously as it deserves
because as we've learned in this video
millions of lives are on the line and I
don't mean in the future I mean now I
don't have a sponsor to promote or a
call to action at the end of this video
my call to action is for you to take
this problem seriously and yes there are
things we can do as individuals to do
that we can not fly we can eat vegan we
can get our electricity from renewable
sources but the most important thing we
can do as individuals is to hold our
governments to account if as I fear is
inevitable they fail in Dubai this year
don't let them get away with it you have
a democratic voice
I suggest you use it thanks musco to
Professor t for agreeing to be
interviewed by me and also to you thank
you for watching if you haven't already
seen it please do go watch my previous
video on the optimistic version of the
21st century it's the biggest best thing
I think I've ever made I was only able
to make that video with the support of
my patrons and that also goes for this
video the names of my executive producer
patrons are on screen right now if you
would like to help me make more and
better videos then you'll find a link to
my patreon down in the description thank
you again for watching and I'll see you
in the next one where hopefully I have
calm down a little
bit